Young men today receive a lot of messages about how they should look. Scroll through social media and you'll find influencers peddling advice on building muscle, losing body fat, improving your jaw line, and maximizing your attractiveness. Entire online communities exist around the idea that a male's appearance can and should be constantly improved. What are these messages doing to men and boys? For years, body image concerns were seen as something that primarily affect, women and girls. But today, there's increasing recognition that boys and men also struggle with body dissatisfaction and eating disorders and that social media might be making the problem worse.
如今的年轻男性接收到大量关于他们应该长什么样的信息。在社交媒体上随意浏览，你就会发现网红们在兜售关于增肌、减脂、改善下颌线以及最大化自身吸引力的建议。整个在线社区都围绕着一个理念：男性的外貌可以而且应该不断地进行改善。这些信息对男性和男孩们造成了什么影响？多年来，身体意象问题一直被视为主要影响女性和女孩的问题。但如今，人们越来越认识到，男孩和男性也同样面临着身体不满和饮食失调的困扰，而社交媒体可能正在加剧这一问题。
So how common are body image concerns among boys and men? In what ways do eating disorders and body dysmorphic disorders in men look different than they look in women and girls? Why do they so often go unrecognized? What role is social media playing in shaping men's perceptions of their body? and what can parents, clinicians, and others do to help boys and men develop a healthy relationship with their appearance. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
那么，身体意象问题在男孩和男性中有多普遍？男性饮食失调和身体畸形恐惧症在表现上与女性和女孩有何不同？为什么它们经常被忽视？社交媒体在塑造男性对自己身体的认知方面扮演了什么角色？家长、临床医生和其他人又能做些什么来帮助男孩和男性建立健康的自我形象关系？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。
My guest today is Dr. Roberto Olavardia, a clinical psychologist at McLean Hospital in Boston and a lecturer in psychology at Harvard Medical School. He and his colleagues coined the term muscle dysmorphia nearly 30 years ago as a subtype of body dysmorphic disorder that primarily affects men. Today he specializes in the treatment of body dysmorphic disorder and eating disorders, as well as ADHD and obsessive-compulsive disorder. He is a co-author of the book The Adonis Complex, the secret crisis of male body obsession. And he's spoken widely to the media about issues related to body. image in boys and men. Dr. Alavardia, thank you for joining me today. Oh, thank you for having me. It's a pleasure. Well, let's start with the big picture. I mentioned in the introduction,
我今天的嘉宾是波士顿麦克莱恩医院的临床心理学家、哈佛医学院心理学讲师罗伯托·奥拉瓦迪亚博士。他和他的同事在近30年前创造了“肌肉畸形恐惧症”这一术语，将其作为主要影响男性的一种身体畸形恐惧症亚型。如今，他专注于治疗身体畸形恐惧症和饮食失调，以及多动症和强迫症。他是《阿多尼斯情结：男性身体痴迷背后的秘密危机》一书的合著者。他曾就男孩和男性的身体意象相关问题在媒体上广泛发言。奥拉瓦迪亚博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。哦，谢谢邀请我。这是我的荣幸。那么，让我们从大局谈起。我在介绍中提到，
that body image is often viewed as concern primarily for girls and women. Why is that and how has our understanding of body image concerns in boys and men changed over the past few decades? Yes. So contrary to what people believe is that 25% of people who have eating disorders are boys and men. Now, many years ago, when I started entering into this research arena, we didn't see that epidemiological data. And part of it was, A, there weren't a lot of studies looking at boys and men, or the assessment measures were not really valid or reliable for male populations. Boys and men were not presenting clinically. And so it was difficult in terms of getting research, because a lot of research on boys and men were just being in the early 90s were being drawn from just clinical
身体意象通常被视为主要是女孩和女性关心的问题。为什么会这样？过去几十年来，我们对男孩和男性身体意象问题的理解发生了怎样的变化？是的。与人们的普遍认知相反，饮食失调患者中有25%是男孩和男性。多年前，当我刚进入这个研究领域时，我们并没有看到这些流行病学数据。部分原因是，A，当时没有多少研究关注男孩和男性，或者评估手段对男性群体来说并不真正有效或可靠。男孩和男性在临床上并没有表现出这些症状。因此，获取研究数据很困难，因为在90年代初，关于男孩和男性的研究大多仅来自临床
samples, which represented just a slice of the boys and men who are struggling. So we know that it's much more common than people think it is. And having done this work for over 30 years, I've seen just increased awareness. And at the same time, there are issues like, as you mentioned, with social media, that are absolutely escalating this issue with boys and men. You and your colleagues coined the term muscle dysmorphia. What is muscle dysmorphia and how is it different from simply wanting to get stronger or more fit? Yes. So in research studies that I was doing at the time on eating disorders, I would get a lot of calls from men who said, well, I don't have an eating disorder, but I used to.
样本，这仅仅代表了那些正在挣扎的男孩和男性中的一小部分。所以我们知道，这种情况比人们想象的要普遍得多。在从事这项工作30多年后，我看到了人们意识的显著提高。与此同时，正如你所提到的，社交媒体等问题正在绝对地加剧男孩和男性的这一问题。你和你的同事创造了“肌肉畸形恐惧症”这个词。什么是肌肉畸形恐惧症？它与单纯想要变得更强壮或更健康有什么不同？是的。当时我在做关于饮食失调的研究时，会接到很多男性的电话，他们说，嗯，我没有饮食失调，但我曾经有过。
I used to have, and many of them would say I used to have anorexia nervosa. and now they would say, I sort of have this other thing where the pendulum kind of swung in the other direction. I'm still obsessed with food and with calories, except I'm eating food, but I'm obsessed with working out. So instead of wanting to be lean, I can't get big enough. I'm worried about losing size. And many of those men with anorexia said that they were never really seeking to be skinny or thin. They were seeking to be lean, which is a little bit different. in male body image than typically what you would see with female populations.
我曾经有过，他们中的许多人会说我曾经患有神经性厌食症。而现在他们会说，我似乎有另一种情况，就像钟摆摆向了另一个方向。我仍然痴迷于食物和卡路里，只不过我是在吃东西，但我痴迷于锻炼。所以，我不是想变得苗条，而是觉得怎么练都不够大。我担心失去肌肉量。许多患有厌食症的男性说，他们从来没有真正追求过变得骨瘦如柴。他们追求的是精瘦，这在男性身体意象中与女性群体通常看到的情况略有不同。
So these were men who were, some of them had disordered eating or full-on clinical eating disorders. Some did not. But they were often, you know, muscular, big guys who were obsessed with working out. When they looked in the mirror, they saw someone who looked scrawny, weak, puny were the words that they would use. And despite people telling them, what are you talking about? you're a big guy, you're muscular, they didn't see it. And even if they saw it, the fear that tomorrow they could lose that drove them to compulsively work out at the gym. Many of them were engaging in anabolic steroid use, engaging in a lot of harmful supplement use, avoiding
所以这些男性中，有些人有饮食失调或完全的临床饮食失调。有些人则没有。但他们通常是肌肉发达的大块头，痴迷于锻炼。当他们照镜子时，他们看到的是一个看起来瘦骨嶙峋、虚弱、弱不禁风的人，这是他们会用的词。尽管人们告诉他们，你在说什么？你是个大块头，你肌肉发达，但他们就是看不见。即使他们看到了，那种明天可能会失去肌肉的恐惧也驱使他们强迫性地在健身房锻炼。他们中的许多人正在使用合成代谢类固醇，使用大量有害的补充剂，回避
situations. And these are not men who are proudly showing off their physiques at Venice Beach, California. The men with muscle dysmorphia were, because they had this distorted body image, are covering their bodies up. They wouldn't leave the house because they felt that they looked too small. So we first kind of coined reverse, is this reverse anorexia? Because it's not always an eating disorder, we really classified it as a subtype of body dysmorphic disorder. And that's where it sort of lies. Are there triggers that essentially push men or boys into body dysmorphia or muscle dysmorphia?
社交场合。这些并不是在加州威尼斯海滩自豪地炫耀身材的男性。患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性，因为他们有这种扭曲的身体意象，反而会遮盖自己的身体。他们甚至不敢出门，因为他们觉得自己看起来太小了。所以我们最初将其称为“反向厌食症”？因为这并不总是一种饮食失调，我们实际上将其归类为身体畸形恐惧症的一个亚型。这就是它所处的位置。有没有什么诱因会本质上将男性或男孩推向身体畸形恐惧症或肌肉畸形恐惧症？
I've read that there's an association, for example, between having been bullied, But a lot of boys who are bullied don't end up with muscle dysmorphia. So what do we know about its ideology? So if we look at this from various lenses, kind of in a bio-psychosocial, social cultural model, so we do know that many of the boys and men with muscle dysmorphia do have, for often family histories of depression, of obsessive-compulsive disorder, of eating disorders. typically psychologically. You'll often hear, I hear a lot in my patients, either histories of being bullied. And sometimes just unlike with girls with negative body image, you'll often find
我读到过，例如，遭受欺凌与此之间存在关联。但许多被欺凌的男孩并没有患上肌肉畸形恐惧症。那么我们对它的病因了解多少？如果我们从不同的视角来看待这个问题，比如生物-心理-社会-文化模型，我们确实知道，许多患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男孩和男性确实有抑郁症、强迫症、饮食失调的家族史。通常在心理上，你会经常听到，我在我的病人身上听到很多，要么是有被欺凌的历史。有时，与对身体意象负面的女孩不同，你经常会发现
that girls who mature earlier are at higher risk of body image issues and receiving unwanted attention for their bodies. With boys, it's the opposite. The boys who mature later tend to be at higher risk. And when I say being bullied, particularly, I mean, sometimes for things that are unrelated to appearance, but being bullied for appearance is not always being bullied for having a larger body, but actually being bullied for being too thin. Because with male body image, being thin is associated with being, quote unquote, weak and not being masculine enough. And so the idea of building this muscular body now became more than just, oh, I want to have this big body. It's kind of this armor of masculinity and the symbol that that sort of represents.
那些发育较早的女孩患身体意象问题的风险更高，并且会因为她们的身体而受到不必要的关注。而男孩则相反。发育较晚的男孩往往风险更高。当我提到被欺凌时，我特别指的是，有时是因为与外貌无关的事情，但因为外貌被欺凌并不总是因为身体肥胖，实际上是因为太瘦而被欺凌。因为在男性身体意象中，瘦与所谓的“虚弱”和“不够阳刚”联系在一起。因此，建立这种肌肉发达的身体的想法现在不仅仅是“哦，我想拥有一个大块头”，它更像是阳刚之气的盔甲，以及它所代表的某种象征。
We also know I see as far as comorbid or associated disorders, things like depression. Social anxiety disorder is actually a very common one. And what I hear from a lot of my patients will say, you know, I feel so awkward in social situations and particularly in dating kind of romantic relationships that if I just look a certain way, my body can sort of do the speaking for me, you know, in a way. And of course, we know that that doesn't work. I mean, it might have people approach you, but then you still have to talk and converse. And then from a sociocultural manner that there's no question that, I mean, unlike with women who historically have been promoted these sort of imagery, this imagery of thinness, I mean, going back
我们还知道，我看到的共病或相关疾病，比如抑郁症。社交焦虑症实际上是非常常见的一种。我从很多病人那里听到他们会说，你知道，我在社交场合感到非常尴尬，特别是在约会这种浪漫关系中，如果我看起来是某种样子，我的身体就能替我说话，你知道，在某种程度上。当然，我们知道这行不通。我的意思是，它可能会让人接近你，但之后你仍然需要交谈和沟通。然后从社会文化的角度来看，毫无疑问，与历史上一直被推崇这种瘦削形象的女性不同，追溯到
to the 1600s, with boys and men, it's been a little bit different that in our research, we found that it was really the late 70s and early 80s where we really saw this sort of promotion of muscular bodies. I mean, if you think, you know, as a kid that grew up in the 80s, the biggest box office stars were Sylvester Stallone and Arnold Schwarzenegger, who their bodies were like kind of a commodity. And Calvin Klein ads and sort of more sort of men featured in advertisements with their chest and the fitness boom and bodybuilding kind of really kind of came into it men's fitness and health magazines exploded and i have to tell you i mean social media being doing this work unlike any other condition diagnosis that i work with i have never seen something
17世纪，对于男孩和男性来说，情况有点不同。在我们的研究中，我们发现直到70年代末和80年代初，我们才真正看到这种对肌肉发达身体的推崇。我的意思是，如果你想一想，作为一个在80年代长大的孩子，最大的票房明星是西尔维斯特·史泰龙和阿诺德·施瓦辛格，他们的身体就像一种商品。还有卡尔文·克莱恩的广告，以及更多在广告中展示胸部的男性，健身热潮和健美运动真正进入了人们的视野，男士健身和健康杂志如雨后春笋般涌现。我必须告诉你，社交媒体，从事这项工作，与我所处理的任何其他疾病诊断不同，我从未见过有哪种事物在社会文化层面上受到如此大的影响，就像社交媒体对身体意象的影响一样。我的意思是，它在这个问题上火上浇油。我们将更多地讨论这个问题，但我先问一个问题，你是如何知道一个人何时从单纯想要变得健康和好看，跨越到了患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的程度？换句话说，你是如何诊断这种疾病的？是的，这是一个很好的问题，因为这很容易被错过，因为不像
be so impacted by something on a sociocultural level as i have with the impact of social media on body image i mean it put gasoline on a fire with this issue. We're going to talk about that more, but I want to ask a question about how you know when somebody has crossed over from just wanting to be fit and looking good to having muscle dysmorphia. In other words, how do you diagnose this? Yeah, it's a great question because this can be easily missed because unlike something like
厌食症那样，当一个人营养不良和消瘦时，有时会变得更加明显，我们反而会庆祝。你知道，如果有一个十几岁的男孩每周去健身房五天，人们会觉得，太棒了。他没有每天玩14个小时的电子游戏，而且他很活跃。我通常把它分为这些不同的类别。第一，是否存在身体意象扭曲？所以对于患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的人来说，他们看到的自己与别人看到的他们是不一样的。他们周围有一种绝望感，他们去健身房不仅仅是因为他们喜欢，而且，你知道，他们想锻炼肌肉并感到自信。他们觉得他们必须这样做。我的意思是，我合作过的许多患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性讨厌去健身房。他们讨厌锻炼。他们觉得被它囚禁了，就像被它奴役了一样，这是他们描述它的方式。但对他们来说，如果他们不这样做，有时真的会让他们陷入，我的意思是，有时会陷入抑郁，甚至自杀的状态。比如疫情期间，我的意思是，对很多这些人来说非常非常困难，健身房关闭了，他们对某些事物的可及性受到了影响。所以，是否存在身体意象扭曲？因为如果一个人开始时就没有准确地看待自己，那就是一个危险信号，这意味着他们所看到的健康边界将是非常不同的，事情可能会变得不健康。另一部分是它在多大程度上阻碍了他们的生活？如果你的生活中还有其他事情。如果你有一个人每天锻炼一小时，他们完成了锻炼，然后，你知道，他们专注于学习、工作和人际关系。太棒了。这没什么错。当它开始优先于其他事情时，我的患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的病人，有些人因为在健身房而被解雇了。他们无法停止锻炼，上班迟到两个小时，或者觉得必须提前下班。有些人，
anorexia where sometimes it becomes more obvious when someone is malnourished and emaciated, we celebrate. You know, if you have a teenage boy that's going to the gym five days a week, it's like, great. He's not playing video games 14 hours a day and he's active. I usually put it in these different categories. One is, is there a presence of a body image distortion? So with people with muscle dysmorphia, they're not seeing themselves the way that other people are seeing them. There's a sort of like desperation that they feel around they're not just going to the
他们中的许多人，许多关系已经结束，因为他们的伴侣会说，你太痴迷于锻炼了，或者你在过去几个小时里问了我一百次，你是否比那个家伙或这个人更大，你看起来是否比昨天更小，以及那种寻求安慰、强迫性寻求安慰的行为？所以他们可能会失去人际关系。他们可能会失去工作。他们很痴迷。对于肌肉畸形恐惧症，周围有很多强迫性的思维。有很多强迫性的行为，无论是锻炼、照镜子、测量自己、称重，还是用皮脂钳来测量体脂。所以这些男性中的许多人知道，这不正常。这不应该完全支配我所有的想法和行动。
gym because they enjoy it and, you know, they want to build their muscle and feel confident. They feel like they have to. I mean, many of the men that I work with with muscle dysmorphia hate going to the gym. They hate working out. They feel imprisoned to it, like enslaved by it, is how they sort of describe it. But the feeling for them, if they don't do that, can really plummet them sometimes into, I mean, depressive, if not suicidal states at times. Like the pandemic was I mean, very, very hard for a lot of these people where gyms were closed and their accessibility to certain things. So is there a body image distortion? Because if someone is starting from a place where they're not seeing themselves accurately, that's a red flag, that there's a higher
所以这是另一部分。当然，另一部分是当它侵入到非常不健康的行为时。所以，你知道，锻炼和运动对我们的健康有好处。但现在如果你开始使用物质，使用合成代谢类固醇或有害的补充剂，现在正在损害你的健康，如果你正在发展成饮食失调或有非常紊乱的饮食行为，影响了你的健康，那么现在我们知道这并没有实现健康的价值。如果你，你知道，我有病人有时会强迫性地举重
risk in terms of where they see that boundary is going to be very different of health and where things can not be healthy. The other part is how much is it getting in the way? have other things in their life. If you have someone who's working out every day, an hour a day, they do their workout, then, you know, they attend to their studies or their jobs and their relationships. Great. There's nothing wrong with that. Where it starts to take precedence over other things, my patients who come in with muscle dysmorphia, some of them have gotten fired from jobs because they're at the gym. They can't stop working out, and they're two hours late for work, or they feel like they have to leave work early. Some of them,
或进行锻炼，而他们的身体非常痛苦，以至于他们开始服用阿片类药物。我曾与许多患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性合作，他们因为锻炼过度导致的慢性疼痛而产生了阿片类药物依赖。然后这显然就成了他们自己的问题和麻烦。另一部分是我会问病人，你的自尊和身份在多大程度上取决于你的外表？对于某些人来说，将自尊的一部分建立在“嘿，我喜欢我的外表”上并没有错，但它不能成为一个主导因素
of them, many relationships have ended because their partners are like, you're just so obsessed with like working out, or you're asking me a hundred times in the last couple hours, whether you're bigger than that guy or this guy, do you look smaller than you did yesterday and sort of that reassurance, compulsive reassurance seeking behaviors? So they can lose relationships. They can lose jobs. They're obsessed. With muscle dysmorphic, there's a lot of obsessive thinking around it. There's a lot of compulsive behaviors, whether it's working out, whether it's mirror checking, measuring themselves, weighing themselves, putting skin body fat calipers to measure their body fat. So a lot of these men know, like, this is not normal. Like this shouldn't be totally dominating, you know, all of my thoughts and my actions.
因为我们都知道，金，我的意思是，真正能创造我们身份并伴随我们一生的东西是那些结晶化的因素，我们的智力、我们的幽默感、我们与人相处的方式，这些东西在我们一生中基本保持一致。我能保证唯一会改变的就是你的外表。我今天看起来的样子将与20年后我看起来的样子以及我的身体能做的事情大不相同。你无法阻止时钟。你无法阻止时钟。
So that's another piece. Certainly the other piece is when it encroaches into very unhealthy behaviors. So, you know, working out and exercise is great for our health. But now if you're engaging in substance use, anabolic steroid use or harmful supplements that are now harming your health, if you are developing an eating disorder or having very disordered eating behaviors that are impacting your health, well, then now we know that's not fulfilling the value of health. If you're, you know, I have patients who sometimes they compulsively lift weight.
这对许多这些男性来说是令人恐惧的，他们，你知道，通常有很多，再次强调，这种高度完美主义的特质，需要控制事物。你只能做这么多，你知道，控制身体这么多。所以当人们侵入这些领域时，我们就知道有问题了，而不是那些可能只是健身爱好者，这只是他们生活的一部分，他们有活跃的社交生活，他们很健康，睡得好，吃得好，那就不是问题。出于好奇，你见过女性患肌肉畸形恐惧症吗？是的，肌肉畸形恐惧症绝对可以影响女性。我的意思是，它主要影响男性。
or do exercise and their body's in so much pain that they start taking opiates. And I've worked with many men with muscle dysmorphia who develop opiate dependencies to deal with the chronic pain from working out so much. And then that obviously becomes its own issue and problem. And the other piece is I ask patients, how much of your self-esteem and identity rests upon the way you look? And there's nothing wrong with having some part of our self-esteem for some people be like, like, hey, you know, I like the way I look and my appearance, but it cannot be a dominant factor
部分原因是社会文化上，肌肉发达在男孩和男性中被推崇得更多。但绝对地，我曾与患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的女性合作过。有趣的是，早期的研究中，没有多少研究关注女性的肌肉畸形恐惧症，但其中少数几项研究中，有一项特别发现，高达50%的患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的女性报告有性虐待史或强奸创伤，她们发展出肌肉畸形恐惧症作为一种防御性的、保护性的措施。我在那些可能有创伤史的男性身上也看到了这一点。或者我见过像男同性恋者，例如，患有肌肉畸形恐惧症，他们觉得必须锻炼身体来，你知道，几乎保护自己免受他们在生活中可能经历的同性恋恐惧暴力。所以，是的，绝对。而且类固醇的使用不仅仅是为了身体意象目的而局限于男性。关于肌肉畸形恐惧症有什么好的数据吗？
because we both know Kim, like, I mean, the things that really are going to create our identity and last us through life are those crystallized factors, our intelligence, our sense of humor, the way we relate to people, those things pretty much stay consistent throughout our life. The one thing I can guarantee that will change is the way you look. How I look today is going to be very different than how I look 20 years from now and what my body can do. Can't stop the clock. You can't stop the clock.
我们知道男性人口中的患病率吗？我们并不真正百分之百确定。我可以告诉你，它肯定比我30年前研究它时更普遍了。我在临床上看到的是，它影响的年龄段更年轻，也更年长。所以我看到几乎是一个光谱，几年前，至少我在临床上看到的可能是17到30岁之间。但我正在与年仅12岁的男孩合作，他们使用过合成代谢类固醇，从网上获取补充剂，关注网上那些向尚未发育的身体兜售如此危险信息的网红，我的意思是，从青春期角度来看。所以它变得更加普遍了。
And that is frightening to a lot of these men who, you know, often have a lot, again, this sort of high perfectionistic kind of traits and need to control things. And you can only do so much, you know, and control the body so much. So when people encroach in those territories, that's when we know we have a problem, as opposed to someone who just might be a fitness enthusiast and it's just part of of their lives and they have active social lives, they're healthy, they're sleeping well, eating well, then it's not an issue. Just our curiosity, do you ever see muscle dysmorphia in women? So yes, muscle dysmorphy can absolutely affect women. I mean, it predominantly affects men.
特别是社交媒体，有一个被称为“男性圈”（Manosphere）的整个社区，这些关于锻炼身体的信息往往带有某种厌女色彩，你知道，向年轻男孩和男性宣传，拥有某种身体是他们的义务，其明确目的是为了获得支配地位和权力，并基本上，你知道，基本上从女性手中夺走选择权，如果你是完美的标本，每个人都会被你吸引。这就是被喂给许多年轻男性的东西，如果你不安全感，像我们大多数人一样，
And part of that is because socioculturally that muscularity is sort of much more promoted towards boys and men. But absolutely, I've worked with women who also have muscle dysmorphia. Interestingly, Early studies, there aren't many that have looked at muscle dysmorphia in women, but some of the few out there, one in particular found that up to 50% of the women with muscle dysmorphia reported having a sexual abuse history or rape trauma in their lives, and that they developed sort of muscle dysmorphia as a sort of defensive, protective measure in a lot of ways. I've seen that with men as well who might have histories of trauma. or I've seen like with gay men, for example, of muscle dysmorphia who felt like they had to build their body to sort of, you know, almost protect themselves around homophobic violence that they might have experienced in their lives. So, yeah, absolutely. And steroid use is not just relegated to men for body image purposes. Is there any good data around muscle dysmorphia?
我们是青少年和青春期前，但特别是如果你可能有社交焦虑史，或者你是一个在很多方面感到不足的人，我也专门研究多动症和有学习障碍的人，我看到这与此也有很多关联。这些信息真的可以触动这些年轻男性，让他们认为，好吧，如果这是我，你知道，需要做的，因为谁不想被接受，谁不想被尊重？所以这些价值观没问题。问题是它们被扭曲了，
Do we know the prevalence in the male population? We don't really 100%. I can tell you it's definitely more common now than when I was looking at this 30 years ago. And what I've seen clinically is much more frequency affecting younger ages and older ages too. So I've seen like almost the spectrum where years ago, at least what I would see clinically would be maybe between the ages of like 17 to 30. But I'm working with boys as young as 12 who have used anabolic steroids, who have gotten supplements from the male, who follow influencers online who are espousing such dangerous information to bodies that haven't even developed yet, I mean, from a puberal perspective. So it's become much more common.
在某种意义上，在社交媒体中。所以我们没有一个真实的患病率。我们知道男性饮食失调患者中，再次强调，25%的饮食失调患者是男孩和男性。对于肌肉畸形恐惧症，我们在真正做得很好的流行病学数据方面还没有达到那个程度。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与奥拉瓦迪亚博士讨论社交媒体趋势是如何加剧一些年轻男性的身体意象问题的。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克Optic是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统，找到你的节奏。这座城市需要敏捷，而Optic以精准交付，让每一次驾驶，
And with social media in particular, there's this whole community known as the Manosphere where these sort of, of messaging around building your body that often have these sort of misogynistic undertones to them, you know, promoting to young boys and men that it's their obligation to have a certain body to, for the express purpose of achieving dominance and power and to basically have, you know, basically take the choice out of, you know, women's hands where if you are like the perfect specimen, and everyone is just going to gravitate to you. That's what's being fed to a lot of young men who, if you're insecure, as most of us are,
都非凡。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在Cadillaccanada.ca了解更多。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动公司2025日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克对豪华车的定义。说到社交媒体，最近网上有一个趋势引起了很多关注。他们称之为“外貌最大化”（looks maxing）。对于可能不熟悉这个术语的听众来说，它指的是通过有时非常极端的手段（如手术）来最大化自身身体吸引力的努力。“外貌最大化”的存在告诉我们今天年轻男性面临的压力是什么？是的，这就是有趣的地方，我记得几年前，当我与那些为了外貌改造而做极端事情的年轻男性或男性合作时，
we're teenagers and preteens, but particularly if you might have a history of social anxiety or you're might somebody who feels inadequate in a lot of ways, I also specialize in ADHD and people with learning disabilities, I see that associated a lot with this as well. That messaging can really speak to these young men to think, okay, if this is what I, you know, need to do, because who doesn't want acceptance and who doesn't want to be respected? So those values are fine. The problem is they get perverted,
用锤子敲击下颌线，你知道，谈论敲碎他们的骨头。从诊断的角度来看，这几乎被概念化为精神病行为，因为它太离奇了，太离谱了，你知道，在某种程度上，这个“外貌最大化”社区。你拥有，我的意思是，有一个非常受欢迎的网红就是这么做的。他用凿子凿他的下巴，有很多很多追随者。现在你会觉得，哇，这在诊断上，这几乎已经成为主流了，你知道，在某种程度上。所以对于我的一些年轻病人，他们进来时，并没有那种犹豫感，过去我可能会遇到一些有犹豫的病人，他们会说，是的，我知道这可能是不健康的或
in a sense, in social media. So we don't have a real prevalence. We know with eating disorders in men, again, the 25% of people with eating disorders are boys and men. With muscle dysmorphia, we're not there yet in terms of really well done epidemiological data. We're going to take a break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Olivarnia about how social media trends are exacerbating body image issues among some young men. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19 speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive,
有害的。现在他们会说，哦，我正在做这件事，他们感到自豪，我不希望人们对它感到羞耻，但几乎没有任何关于这可能有多么有害、它实际上可能有多么无效的意识。所以，是的，它可能是像用锤子敲击下颌这样的事情，这种观念，哦，是的，你知道，你可以改变任何你想改变的东西。当然，你必须有无限的经济资源来进行手术。但其中一些网红才20出头，就已经做了20到30次整形手术，下颌提升、下巴植入、颧骨植入和前额提升。
extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. Well, speaking of social media, there's a trend that's gained a lot of attention online recently. They call it looks maxing. And for listeners who might not be familiar with the term, it refers to efforts to maximize your physical attractiveness, sometimes through really extreme measures like surgery. What does the existence of looks maxing tell us about the pressures that young men are facing today? Yeah, this is where it's interesting is I remember years ago when I was working in working with young men or men who were doing very extreme things for appearance modification,
我的意思是，我们谈论的是20岁。但再次强调，信息，有那一部分，这是危险的。但其背后的信息也是一种感觉，即你，这是你某种阳刚之气的义务去这样做。因为如果你不这样做，你将不会，你将成为所谓的“贝塔男”（beta male）。你将成为不足的人。你将成为那个被践踏和碾压的“好人”。而占主导地位的“阿尔法男”（alpha male）将获得
putting a hammer to their jaw line, you know, talking about chipping their bones. From a diagnostic perspective, it was almost conceptualized as psychotic behavior because it was so bizarre and so off the grid, you know, in ways, this is, this looks maxing kind of community. You have, I mean, there's a very popular influencer who does just that. He takes a chisel to his jaw and has many, many followers. And now you're like, wow, like this diagnostically, this isn't, this has almost gone mainstream, you know, in some ways. So with some of my young. patients, they come in and there isn't a sense of almost like a lot of times in the past I might have someone who has some hesitation and they're like, yeah, I know this is kind of probably unhealthy or
接触所有女性的机会，或者在男同性恋者的情况下，获得所有男性以及权力和
harmful. Now they're like, oh, I'm doing this thing and they have pride and I don't want people to feel like shame around it, but there's almost no sense of how harmful this could be, how ineffective it could actually be. And so, yeah, it could be things like putting a hammer to one's jaw, this notion of, oh, yeah, you know, you can change whatever you want to change. Of course, you have to have unlimited financial resources to do surgeries. But some of these influencers are in their young 20s and have had 20 to 30, you know, plastic surgeries, jaw lifts and chin implants and cheekbone implants and forehead lifts.
尊重，这几乎和危险一样。所以，我听到的是，我的意思是，我与患有肌肉畸形恐惧症、有这些身体意象问题的男性进行的第一次会谈中，我问他们，他们在社交媒体上关注谁？他们中的许多人我知道，而我不认识的那些，我立刻开始关注，因为我想知道我在和谁竞争，因为老实说，我们作为心理健康提供者、作为医生的可信度，我甚至不会说与这些网红相当。它几乎低于那个水平，因为某人获得了1000万粉丝，就会产生一种即时的可信度，即当然，他们所说的一定是准确的，你知道，一定是
I mean, we're talking at 20. But again, the mess, there's that piece, which is dangerous. But the messaging behind it, too, is a sense of you, it is your sort of masculine obligation to do this. Because if you don't do this, you are not going to, you will be the quote unquote beta male. You're going to be the inadequate. You're going to be the nice guy that gets stomped on and steamed rolled over. And the dominant alpha male is going to get. access, you know, to all the women, or in the case of gay men, all the men and the power and the
正确的。这就是它如此阴险和危险的地方。所以我与我的病人进行了很多关于他们关注的这些人是谁的对话。让我们来审视一下我们如何变得对这些信息更具辨识力？因为我不责怪个人。我自己也曾是一个容易受影响的青春期男孩。我很高兴我没有在这样的环境下长大。我不责怪个人。
respect, that's what is almost like just as dangerous. And so what I'm hearing one of the, I mean, the first session I have with men who have muscle dysmorphia, who have these body image issues, I ask them, who do they follow on social media? And many of them I know and the ones that I don't know, I instantly start to follow because I want to know who I'm competing against because Because honestly, our credibility as mental health providers, as physicians, as is, I wouldn't even say is on par with these influencers. It's almost like below that because somebody gets 10 million followers, there's this instant credibility that, of course, what they're saying must be accurate, you know, must be
但我认为，我们必须有一个暂停键，并以某种方式审视它，因为确实，我的意思是，有网红，很多我的年轻病人谈论的一个，基本上提倡使用合成代谢类固醇，并说，你知道吗，不要听这些医生，这些婴儿潮一代，他们不知道他们在说什么。他们可能从来没有，你知道，在高中时有过性生活。而且，你知道，有一种感觉，就像，他们是失败者。就像，我是那个拥有所有信息的人，网红说。所以他们会字面上开出服用什么种类的类固醇，在哪里找到
correct. And that's what's so insidious and dangerous around it. And so I have a lot of conversations with my patients around who are these people that they're following. And let's kind of examine how do we become sort of more literate around that? Because I don't blame the individuals. I was an impressionable adolescent boy myself. Like I am glad I did not grow up with this. I don't blame the individual.
它们，在哪里获得它们。我的意思是，这就像一份菜单。现在人们很容易就能弄到很多非常危险的东西。你知道，你谈到了肌肉畸形恐惧症与强迫症和多动症等疾病的重叠。肌肉畸形恐惧症患者，他们是否在某种意义上上瘾了，以至于他们无法停止对身体做这些事情？是的。这绝对有一个因素，你知道，这种完美主义、成瘾行为。我发现许多患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性要么有物质滥用问题，有时他们处于物质滥用问题的康复期。
I think we have to, though, have some pause button and some way of sort of examining that because there is, I mean, there are influencers, one that a lot of my young patients talk about, basically advocates for anabolic steroid use and says, you know what, don't listen to these doctors, these boomers, they don't know what they're talking about. They probably never, you know, had sex in high school. And, you know, there's this sense, like, they're the losers. Like, I'm the one that has all the information, says the influencer. And so we'll literally prescribe what kinds of steroids to take, where to find.
他们经常会说，他们想知道自己是否几乎有某种成瘾转移，它从毒品和酒精转移到了，也许最初是为了在清醒之旅中锻炼身体以保持健康，然后它就变成了一个滑坡。我的许多病人会说他们不知道如何调节。这就是我经常看到的多动症共病。作为一个自己患有多动症的人，我可以感同身受。你知道，调节，你知道，对很多不同的事情来说都很困难。
find them, where to get them. I mean, it is like a menu. It's so easy now for people to get their hands on a lot of very dangerous stuff. You know, you've talked about the overlap with muscle dysmorphia and things like OCD and ADHD. Is muscle dysmorphia, the people who have, are they kind of addicted in the sense that they can't stop doing these things to their bodies? Yes. There is definitely an element to that of you know, this sort of perfectionism, addictive behavior. A number of men with muscle dysmorphia, I find either have a substance abuse issue, sometimes they're in recovery of a substance abuse issue.
所以这种感觉，如果我投入到某件事中，几乎就像我必须150%地投入其中。许多这些男性，他们会告诉我，他们说，我不知道如何不这样。而且，你知道，他们中的许多人被拖进去是因为也许他们被解雇了。也许这是人际关系中的最后通牒。有时是因为他们进来是因为他们受了伤，无法继续锻炼。他们变得非常自杀或非常抑郁，他们意识到这是一个，你知道，问题。也许他们最近参加了健美比赛。
And they will often say, like, they wonder if they have almost like an addiction transfer, that it sort of went from drugs and alcohol to maybe it started out as building their body to be healthy in their sobriety journey. and then it just, there was a slippery slope. And many of my patients will say they don't know how to regulate. And that's where the ADHD I see often that comorbidity. And as someone myself that has ADHD, I can relate. You know, regulation is, you know, hard for a lot of different things.
当你身处，你知道，真正围绕那种文化时。他们意识到，哦，等一下，这有问题。但他们，是的，他们觉得他们无法停止。他们不知道如何摆脱它。另一件事是，这是一个在某种程度上没有获得你可能对，比如说，患有经典神经性厌食症的人所看到的那种同情的群体。
So this sense of if I'm invested in something, it's almost like I'm going to have to be into it, 150%. And many of these men, they will tell me, like, They're like, I don't know how to not to be this way. Like, and, you know, a lot of them kind of are dragged in because maybe they got fired. Maybe it's an ultimatum from a relationship. And sometimes it's they came in, come in because they've had an injury and they can't keep up the workout. And they got very suicidal or very depressed and they realized this is, you know, a problem. Maybe they recently entered a bodybuilding competition.
你看到他们，他们看起来，你知道，他们生病了，消瘦了。没有人会认为，你知道，一个可能250磅、体脂率7%在健身房锻炼的家伙是一个可能正在受苦和挣扎的人。这就是问题所在，我的意思是，我们知道男性总体上。特别是当涉及到男性身体意象和饮食失调时，他们不太可能寻求治疗。但这个群体，更是如此，因为几乎有这种观念。而且有研究实际上观察了即使是提供者，对患有饮食失调的男性也有偏见，更不用说患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性了。我必须告诉你，这是一群男性，他们是其中最敏感、最善良的
And when you're around, you know, really. really around that culture. They realize, oh, wait a minute, this is problematic. But they, yeah, they feel they can't stop. They don't know how to kind of get out of it. And the other thing, too, is that this is a population that doesn't sort of garner the kind of sympathy that you might see for, let's say, someone with classic anorexia nervosa.
个体，有时只是不知道，或者感到一种羞耻感，因为他们是那样被塑造的，因为那是他们被告知的。或者他们正在试图获得一种自信，这很好，但它几乎是以这种过度纠正的方式，你知道，如果我建立这种身体，我就会指挥支配地位和尊重。这绝对是通过社交媒体以一种我从未见过的方式被宣传和喂养的。好吧，让我们谈谈治疗。我的意思是，对于患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性，什么才是有效的？对于男性的治疗与你可能对女性和女孩使用的治疗有什么不同？所以通常在，所以你会有心理教育的结合，关于，你知道，什么是健康的身体，什么是，你知道，期望
You see them, they look, you know, they're sick and they're emaciated. Nobody thinks of, you know, a guy that might be 250 pounds and 7% body fat working out the gym is someone that might be suffering and struggling. And that's what's problematic is that, I mean, we know just men in general. And then particularly when it comes to men in body image and eating disorders are less likely to seek treatment. But this population, even more so, because there's almost this notion. And there are studies that have actually looked at even how providers, have biases around men with eating disorders, let alone men with muscle dysmorphia to really see. And I have to tell you, this is a population of men who are some of the most sensitive, kind of
我的一些病人对于他们应该有多少体脂或多少肌肉量或什么是正常的锻炼的期望是如此扭曲，什么是健康饮食，你知道，这些健康的实践。当我说是健康时，意味着即使对于运动员，比如说，或可能是狂热的举重运动员，这，你知道，我理解一个，比如说，是举重运动员的人会比，你知道，不这样做的人吃得不同。然后是审视一些事情，比如关于社交媒体成本的素养，内容以及他们正在接收什么样的信息。然后治疗与你在女性身上看到的类似，比如认知行为疗法，它正在审视人们可能有的这些不准确的
individuals who sometimes just don't know or either feel a sense of shame that they're wired that way, because that's what they've been told. or they are trying to gain a level of assertiveness, which is fine, but it's almost in this kind of overcorrected way that, you know, if I build this sort of body, I'm just going to command dominance and respect. And that is absolutely being promoted and fed through social media in a way I've just never seen before. Well, let's talk about treatments. I mean, what is effective for men in particular who, who are you who, have muscle dysmorphia and are treatments for men different from what you might use with women and girls so generally it wouldn't be that much different in terms of so you'd have a combination of psychoeducation in terms of you know what is a healthy body what is a you know the expectations that
想法。例如，一个患有肌肉畸形恐惧症的男性可能会说，好吧，你知道，当我参加聚会时，我知道人们看着我并想，哦，他看起来有点瘦弱。通过认知疗法，我们不会说，哦，不，那是一个错误的想法。我们说，好吧，那个想法的证据是什么？你知道，让我们，我不知道人们是否在那样想。我不是通灵者，但证据是什么？如果证据是，哦，我只是觉得他们是。好吧，我们可以感觉很多事情。
some of my patients have around how much body fat they should have or how much muscle mass or what is normal working out is so skewed that what is healthy eating, you know, these healthy sort of practices. And when I say healthy, meaning even healthy for an athlete, let's say, or someone who might be an avid weightlifter, which, you know, I understand someone who, let's say, is a weightlifter is going to maybe eat differently than, you know, somebody who doesn't do that. Then there's sort of looking at things like the sort of literacy around what social media costs. content and sort of what messaging they're getting. And then the treatments are similar to what you would see with women, things like cognitive behavioral therapy, which is examining these inaccurate
我们可以感觉自己很笨但并不笨。我们可以感觉自己很丑但并不丑。就像，我们可以感觉很多事情。然后我们知道的是，行为部分是意识到我们正在做哪些行为，这些行为正在助长这种障碍，以及我们在回避行为方面没有做哪些行为，这些行为正在助长这种障碍。然后我们从ACT（接纳承诺疗法）中汲取，它代表接纳和承诺疗法，它真正审视某种价值，它就像一种以价值为导向的疗法。
thoughts that people might have. For example, a man with muscle dysmorphia might say, well, you know, when I go to a party, I know people are looking at me and thinking, oh, he looks kind of scrawny. And with cognitive therapy, we don't say, oh, no, that's a wrong thought. we say, well, what's the evidence for that thought? You know, let's, I don't know if people are thinking that or not. I'm not psychic, but what is the evidence? And if the evidence is, oh, I just feel that they are. Well, we can feel lots of things.
这是一个多年的问题。我会问人们，你知道，这的最终目标是什么？所以，好吧，你正在建立这个身体或以某种方式塑造这个身体，但这并不是真的仅仅为了好看。价值是什么？它的货币是什么？我几乎普遍听到同样的事情。我想要接受。我想要尊重。我想要被爱。我想要，你知道，基本上免受批评，当然，我们谁都不会免疫于
We can feel dumb and not be dumb. We can feel ugly and not be ugly. Like, we can feel a lot of things. And then what we know is that the behavioral part is being aware of what behaviors we're doing that are feeding into the disorder and what behaviors we're not doing in terms of avoidant behaviors that are feeding the disorder. Then we sort of draw in from Act, which stands for acceptance and commitment therapies, which really look at sort of the value, it's like a value-oriented therapy.
批评。我告诉我的病人，那些是伟大的价值观。你知道，我们都，那些是人类的价值观，被爱，被接受，被连接。这没有任何病理学与之相关。问题是，我总是几乎将这种障碍人格化或使其成为与人不同的东西，以说，好吧，饮食失调或肌肉畸形恐惧症在对你撒谎，因为它让你认为你将通过这种障碍更接近那个价值。这是一个谎言。它不是。事实上，它正在做完全相反的事情。它正在把你从那些价值观中推开。一个完美的例子就是我在我的第一个研究中，我在我的第一个研究中，我在我的第一个研究中。
And this is a question for years. I would ask people, you know, what's the ultimate goal in this? So, okay, you're building this body or you're shaping this body in a certain way, but it's not really just for the sake of just looking good. What's the value? What's the currency of it? I almost universally hear the same thing. I want acceptance. I want respect. I want to be loved. I want to, you know, basically be free of criticism, which of course, none of us are going to be immune to
这是一个困扰多年的问题。我会问人们，你知道，这背后的终极目标是什么？所以，好吧，你在塑造这个身体，或者以某种方式改变它，但这不仅仅是为了好看。它的价值是什么？它的意义何在？我几乎总是听到同样的回答。我想要被接纳。我想要被尊重。我想要被爱。我想要，你知道，基本上免受批评，当然，我们谁也无法完全避免批评。
criticism. And I tell my patients, those are great values. You know, we all, those are human values to be loved, to be accepted, to be connected. There's no pathology associated with that. The problem is, and I always kind of almost personify the disorder or make it something different than the person to say, well, an eating disorder or muscle dysmorphia is lying to you because it's making you think you're going to get closer to that value through the disorder. And it's a lie. That it's not. In fact, it's doing the very opposite. It's moving you away from those values. And a perfect example of that was in my very first research study I did on my first research study I did on my
我告诉我的病人，这些都是很好的价值观。你知道，我们所有人，被爱、被接纳、与人建立联系，这些都是人类的价值观。这本身并没有病理学上的问题。问题在于——我总是倾向于将这种障碍人格化，或者把它看作与人本身不同的东西——进食障碍或肌肉畸形恐惧症在对你撒谎，因为它让你以为通过这种障碍，你就能更接近那些价值观。这是一个谎言。事实并非如此。事实上，它恰恰相反。它正在让你远离那些价值观。我做的第一个研究项目就是一个完美的例子。
muscle dysmorphia. And this was a man who said, please feel free to share this example for as many years. Very bright guy. And he, in his mid-20s, working out five hours a day, was taking multiple anabolic steroids, obsessed looking in the mirror, whatnot. He had already had some adverse health consequences. He had a severe kidney infection that put him at a very high risk of losing a kidney because of his substance use. Chronic pain, which had him addicted to New Bain, which was a painkiller, cystic acne, erectile dysfunction, hair loss. And I said, what is, I asked him that same question. What's the ultimate? And he said, I just, I just want, you know, women, I just want to be successful with women. I mean, his exact quote was, I want to get chicks,
肌肉变形障碍。这是一个男士，他说，请随意分享这个例子，很多年了。他非常聪明。在他20多岁时，每天锻炼五个小时，服用多种合成代谢类固醇，沉迷于照镜子等等。他已经遭受了一些不利的健康后果。由于滥用药物，他患有严重的肾脏感染，面临极高的肾衰竭风险。慢性疼痛使他沉迷于止痛药New Bain，还有囊性痤疮、勃起功能障碍、脱发。我问了他同样的问题：你的终极目标是什么？他说，我只是，我只是想，你知道，女人，我只是想在女人面前成功。我的意思是，他的原话是，我想泡妞，
was sort of his quote. And I said to him, and not in a mocking way, but I was like, but you understand like everything you're doing, you have no opportunity to. Like your body is burnt out. You have erectile dysfunction. You're so worn out. You know, your life is at the gym. Like, where are you even going to meet these people? And he stopped and he looked at me in all sincerity.
这算是他的原话。我并没有嘲笑的意思，但我对他说，但你要明白，你所做的一切，你根本没有机会。你的身体已经透支了。你有勃起功能障碍。你太疲惫了。你知道，你的生活就在健身房里。你甚至要去哪里见这些人？他停下来，非常真诚地看着我。
I was like, wow, I never thought of that. And that was such a learning experience for me to think, wow, this is how deep someone can really be in a disorder that the very thing they feel. think they're seeking is like it just gets lost it's over you know over time so that act acceptance and commitment therapy really goes into like what are the values that we're really trying to you know espouse it can involve nutritional therapy having a nutritionist on board medications can be helpful particularly because depression a mood disorders anxiety disorders are very common in this population.
我当时想，哇，我从来没想过这一点。这对我来说是一次非常深刻的学习经历，让我意识到，一个人陷入某种障碍可以有多深，以至于他们认为自己正在追求的东西，随着时间的推移，最终会丢失。因此，接纳承诺疗法（ACT）确实深入探讨了我们真正想要推崇的价值观是什么。它可能涉及营养疗法，聘请营养师，药物治疗也可能有所帮助，特别是考虑到抑郁症、情绪障碍和焦虑症在这一人群中非常普遍。
And then for people who might be married or family or couples therapy could also be helpful. So it would be very similar things. The difference with women and men is undoubtedly the conversation around the meaning of muscle and the sort of construct of masculinity comes up a lot, you know, in terms of what does it mean to be a man? And interestingly, in this climate that we're in is really a very interesting thing. because there's there's so much again this sort of really negative messaging that's sort of in this manosphere culture on social media of these very kind of archaic ways of what it means to be a man so that discussion but it's not dissimilar that with women let's say with eating disorders
对于已婚人士或家庭，夫妻治疗也可能有所帮助。所以情况非常相似。男性和女性的区别无疑在于关于肌肉意义的对话，以及关于男子气概的建构，这在关于“做一个男人意味着什么”的讨论中经常出现。有趣的是，在我们所处的这种气候下，这确实是一件非常有趣的事情。因为社交媒体上的“男性圈”文化中，充斥着大量关于“做一个男人意味着什么”的非常负面的、陈旧的信息。所以这种讨论，与女性的饮食失调讨论并没有什么不同，
who might want to achieve a certain ideal to be quote unquote more feminine those discussions could be what does it mean to be a woman and, you know, in that kind of way. So it's, it's similar, but it's just a different kind of perspective. Well, let me ask a question for the parents among our listeners. What are some of the warning signs that they should be looking for if they're concerned, say that their son is struggling with muscle dysmorphia or body image concerns? Well, first, I think it's so important for parents to know if your child is on social media, who are they following? That's because when you know who someone is following to understand that unlike magazines and advertisements and movies and those, that kind of imagery that years ago we were talking about, social media, as you know, is curated for an individual where in a given day they can be exposed to hundreds to thousands of imagery, of video posts.
那些可能想要达到某种理想以变得“更女性化”的人，这些讨论可能就是“做一个女人意味着什么”。所以，它们是相似的，只是视角不同。那么，让我为听众中的父母问一个问题。如果他们担心自己的儿子正在与肌肉变形障碍或身体形象问题作斗争，他们应该寻找哪些警示信号？首先，我认为父母了解孩子在社交媒体上关注谁非常重要。因为当你了解某人关注谁时，就会明白，与多年前我们谈论的杂志、广告和电影中的那种图像不同，社交媒体是为个人量身定制的，在一天之内，他们可能会接触到成百上千的图像和视频帖子。
Some of them could even be personalized for individuals. and you're seeing other people's responses to that. Other people that might be saying, oh, wow, I did this and it worked and this and this and this. This is like, I mean, no pun, I guess pun intended, but this is like all of that on steroids, you know, all of that media imagery we were talking about from two decades ago, you know, to a whole other level. And with curiosity, I say with parents, you know, lean into it like, oh, who are you following?
其中一些甚至可能是为个人量身定制的。你会看到其他人对此的反应。其他人可能会说，哦，哇，我做了这个，它奏效了，诸如此类。这就像是——没有双关的意思，或者说双关语——这就像是把我们二十年前谈论的所有媒体图像都加了类固醇，提升到了一个全新的水平。我建议父母们保持好奇心，去了解一下，比如，你关注了谁？
And then rather than, oh, my gosh, you shouldn't follow this, this is looking. into their stuff and then have conversations with your child around, you know, tell me what you find appealing about this person, you know, and with trying not to have judgment, even though, you know, obviously as parents were going to be, you know, concerned because what you want is really to have a conversation. And a lot of times with the kids, young or teens that I work with, when I ask them that question, you know, they'll tell me, oh, and sometimes they'll say, oh, I know this, what he does and talks about with this is a little out there, but this stuff is normal. But the thing is, I notice in my patients the stuff that they regard as being like really out there
而不是说，哦，天哪，你不应该关注这个。而是去了解他们的内容，然后与你的孩子进行对话，比如，告诉我你觉得这个人哪里吸引你。尽量不要带有评判，尽管作为父母，我们显然会感到担心，因为你真正想要的是进行对话。很多时候，当我问我辅导的孩子或青少年这个问题时，他们会告诉我，有时他们会说，哦，我知道他做的和谈论的这些有点离谱，但这些东西很正常。但问题是，我注意到我的病人们，那些他们认为非常离谱的东西，
one month later that year, it's not so out there anymore. And this affects all of us. I mean, this isn't just for young people. I mean, we just have become so desensitized in so many ways that what seems so outrageous one week could be sort of in the mainstream. So I think there's that piece. If you notice that, you know, your son, if they're verbal about their sort of language around their body, you know, oh, I'm, you know, scrawny if they're like really being picky in a way now, part of this is also not unusual, certainly for adolescents where our bodies are growing and developing and it can be awkward at times. But if that language gets, is frequent, if it's intense and it's negativity, if you see that they're sort of looking at,
一个月后，那一年，就不再那么离谱了。这影响着我们所有人。我的意思是，这不仅仅针对年轻人。我们已经在很多方面变得麻木了，以至于一周前看起来如此令人震惊的事情，可能很快就会成为主流。所以我认为有这一部分。如果你注意到你的儿子，如果他们对自己的身体语言表达得很明确，比如，哦，我很瘦弱，如果他们现在变得非常挑剔，当然，部分原因对于青少年来说并不罕见，因为我们的身体正在生长发育，有时会感到尴尬。但如果这种语言变得频繁、强烈且充满负面情绪，如果你看到他们似乎在，
at mirrors a lot or taking selfies a lot, you know, refusing to wear certain clothes because they feel that those clothes kind of shows a part of their body that they don't like or don't show. And, you know, with, again, some of us might have that within reason, especially in puberty, but where it starts to get almost like too extreme, like, oh, I can't, if they're eating habits, so I can't eat this and this and this and this and this and this and it starts to, because, you You know, I often see something like muscle dysmorphia as, interestingly, like the body, the whole pursuit is the body getting bigger, but their world is getting smaller in many ways. They start to associate only with other people who are kind of in that world, as opposed to when
频繁照镜子或频繁自拍，拒绝穿某些衣服，因为他们觉得那些衣服会显露出他们不喜欢或不想展示的身体部位。当然，我们有些人可能会在合理范围内这样做，特别是在青春期，但当它开始变得过于极端时，比如，哦，我不能……如果他们的饮食习惯，我不能吃这个、这个、这个……它就开始……因为你知道，我经常看到像肌肉变形障碍这样的东西，有趣的是，整个追求过程是身体变得更大，但他们的世界在很多方面却变得更小了。他们开始只与那些处于那个圈子里的人交往，而不是像
it's healthy exercise or whatnot, they can still have friends who maybe aren't always into that. But with muscle dysmorphia, because it's almost so all-consuming that a lot of these men end up finding only kind of comfort in other people that are sort of obsessed with it in that kind of way. Certainly if your son is, you know, not wanting to go out or avoiding things because they feel they don't look a certain way, I always say, you know, it's always to be proactive and just, you know, get some help and support. Because even if it's something that's emerging and turns out to be quote unquote normal puberty, but that's still important. I mean, we don't want anyone feeling bad, you know, about their bodies. I mean, there's even what we call quote unquote
健康锻炼时那样，他们仍然可以有不总是沉迷于此的朋友。但对于肌肉变形障碍，因为它几乎占据了全部，以至于许多这些男性最终只在那些同样沉迷于此的人身上找到安慰。当然，如果你的儿子不想出门或回避某些事情，因为他们觉得自己的外表不够好，我总是说，保持主动，寻求一些帮助和支持。因为即使它只是刚刚出现，结果证明只是所谓的“正常青春期”，那也很重要。我的意思是，我们不希望任何人对自己的身体感到难过。我的意思是，甚至有所谓的“规范性”
normative still can have its wounds, you know, and its scars. So, you know, the earlier you catch it, you know, certainly the better. But also to normalize it because especially with boys, what I hear a lot from parents, and I feel, you know, because of course, every parent loves their child and wants the best for them. But very often I'll hear from moms and dads who say, you know, I know not to talk about my body or negative stuff, body image to my daughter. I never occurred to me how I talk about, and this is sometimes like from moms who maybe they had a history of an eating disorder, that they're like, it never occurred to me that when I call myself ugly, that that could affect how my son looks. You know, I knew not to say that in front of my daughter.
仍然会留下伤口和疤痕。所以，越早发现越好。但也要将其正常化，因为特别是对于男孩，我从父母那里听到了很多，我感同身受，因为当然，每个父母都爱他们的孩子，想要给他们最好的。但我经常听到妈妈和爸爸们说，我知道不要在女儿面前谈论我的身体或负面的身体形象。我从来没想过我谈论的方式……有时这来自那些可能有饮食失调史的妈妈们，她们说，我从来没想过，当我称自己丑陋时，那可能会影响我儿子的看法。我知道不要在女儿面前那样说。
And this is what I see is that it, you know, it's not just the fathers that they're looking. It's how bodies and body image and appearance is talked about within a family. And not to say that it's a causal factor. It's one of many factors. But having conversations, too, around, you know, how do we talk to ourselves about the way we look? And for parents to be vulnerable, too, to say, you know, yeah, you know, I remember when I was younger and, you know, things that were so impactful in terms of how I felt about myself, you know, it took me a while. Because what kids and or young people don't want to hear is, oh, looks don't matter.
这就是我所看到的，不仅仅是父亲们在观察。这是关于家庭内部如何谈论身体、身体形象和外表。并不是说这是一个因果因素。它是众多因素之一。但也要进行对话，关于我们如何谈论自己的外表。父母也要表现得脆弱一点，说，是的，我记得我年轻的时候，那些对我对自己感觉的影响有多大，我花了一段时间才走出来。因为孩子们或年轻人不想听到的是，哦，外表不重要。
You know, that like, you know, because the truth is they kind of do, but not to the degree that the patients that I work with see it to be. And that's where the second you say, and for therapists out there too, because I have a lot of patients that have said, oh, I worked with the therapist. who said, oh, that's like vanity, you know, that doesn't matter. And now the patient's like, oh, okay, so I guess you think I'm vain or narcissistic and narcissistic. So, okay, this isn't going to work. Whereas I tell my patients, like, I completely understand because I know if I grew up with this, I would have been at risk, you know, for some of it. It's like it's just so all-consuming.
你知道，因为事实是它们确实重要，但没有我辅导的病人所认为的那种程度。这就是为什么当你这么说时，对于治疗师来说也是如此，因为我有很多病人说，哦，我找过一个治疗师，他说，哦，那是虚荣，那不重要。现在病人会想，哦，好吧，所以我猜你认为我很虚荣或自恋。好吧，这行不通。而我告诉我的病人，我完全理解，因为我知道如果我在这种环境下长大，我也会面临风险。这简直太让人沉迷了。
So I get it because we don't want to like pathologize the individual from the person. We want to pathology, like the behaviors and those kinds of things are the things that are getting them into trouble. But it's helpful to, you know, hear how, you know, we all kind of have these kinds of strange relationships sometimes, you know, with our bodies. And some people don't. Some people are sort of neutral about it. But even having those conversations without necessarily pointing out things. And then if there are certain behaviors for parents to share, like, you know, I've noticed, because it's one. one thing to say, I think you have a problem with X, Y, and Z, especially your adolescence, is going to be like, well, they won't hear that. They're not going to hear that. But if you say,
所以我明白，因为我们不想把个体病理化。我们想要病理化的是行为，那些让他们陷入麻烦的事情。但听到我们所有人有时与身体之间都有这种奇怪的关系是有帮助的。有些人没有。有些人对此持中立态度。但即使在不一定指出具体事情的情况下进行这些对话，如果父母发现某些行为，比如，我注意到了，因为说“我认为你在某某方面有问题”是一回事，特别是对于青少年，他们会说，好吧，他们不会听的。他们不会听的。但如果你说，
you know, I notice you're not going out as much as you used to with your friends and you're a very social person. Hmm. Like, what's up with that? Like, if you're sharing an observation that's concrete, you know, then I notice, like, what are all, there's these 20 supplements that you're taking. Like, what, what is all of this? And, you know, we have to make sure. that this is healthy. Like, let's run this by your primary care physician. Because oftentimes the battles may be like, oh, no, you're not going to take X, Y, and Z. And the person's like, well, this is, you know, healthy. And I say to parents, like, just take it out of your hands and say, well, if it's healthy, let's run them by your PCP. And, you know, that way it's not this sort of
你知道，我注意到你不像以前那样经常和朋友出去了，你是一个非常善于社交的人。嗯，这是怎么回事？如果你分享一个具体的观察，然后我注意到，你正在服用的这20种补充剂是什么？这到底是什么？而且，我们必须确保这是健康的。让我们让你的初级保健医生检查一下。因为很多时候，争论可能是，哦，不，你不能服用这个那个。而那个人会说，好吧，这是健康的。我对父母说，把它从你的手中拿走，说，如果它是健康的，让我们让你的全科医生检查一下。这样它就不会变成那种
parental sort of, you know, kind of struggle as much as I just want you to be healthy. And the truth is, And again, some of these supplements are fine. Some of them are totally ineffective and some are harmful. And when you're, you know, I wouldn't even say young. Because honestly, I work with men in their 30s and 40s with this who will buy stuff. And it turns out can have very harmful side effects. Well, Dr. Olavaria, I want to thank you for joining me. I think this has been very illuminating.
父母式的挣扎，我只是希望你健康。事实是，再说一次，有些补充剂没问题。有些完全无效，有些是有害的。当你，我甚至不会说年轻。因为老实说，我辅导过30多岁和40多岁的男性，他们会买这些东西。结果证明可能会有非常有害的副作用。好吧，Olavaria博士，我想感谢你加入我的节目。我认为这非常有启发性。
I hope our listeners get a lot of good information from what you said. It's very helpful. Oh, thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association.
我希望我们的听众能从你所说的话中获得很多有用的信息。这非常有帮助。哦，谢谢你邀请我。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。